thank you
[Music]
did you see did you see any of the news
this morning at all about Trump is he
actually arrested he thinks he is he's
getting arrested he claims that on
Tuesday so I mean today's Saturday that
on Tuesday he will be arrested or he'll
be indicted was that his real Twitter I
thought that was it yeah is he back on
Twitter he said no it's his it's his
truth this is this is his word for word
uh his word for word post is the Far and
Away leading Republican candidate and
former president of the United States of
America will be arrested on Tuesday of
next week protest take our nation back
so that's all he said that's what I said
so he's inciting April 6th huh April 6
is a good date April 6th will be trying
to make an April 6 go go down there's
nothing else that goes oh my God so
crazy about April Fool's thing damn Joe
thinks it's like
late don't tell him
wait just wait it's so so you know what
though it's like so confusing I don't
know if I'm just like an idiot I'm
trying to read through all these like
different articles and listen to all
these things to make sense of this and I
just I can't understand it but I can
understand what he's being
um accused so like why are they
arresting campaign Finance violation I
believe that's um so that's one thing
that's interesting Taco Carlson was
saying that he thinks it's um it's the
falsifying of documents or something my
business records but that's a
misdemeanor and they're trying to uh the
the D.A of Manhattan is seeking to
upgrade that to a felony somehow by
sticking another charge on top of it
which might be connected to the Stormy
Daniels thing yeah I think I think it's
all all right if he gets if he gets
charged with the felony he can't run he
can't run that's what people are saying
but Elon Elon tweeted that if he gets
arrested he thinks that Trump is going
to become president for sure
I think I don't think that's a bad guess
how does that any time that the system
has tried to come down on him that way
his approval rating soared
dude he's gonna be president again I
have a [__] feeling isn't it funny
how like well I didn't know that
I didn't know that the Hillary campaign
actually
um was was pumping money and funding
Trump to because they wanted to knock
him like they thought that he yeah he
was an easier opponent to be versus
who's the other person
um Don Cheadle no no not I mean it
couldn't be Bernie Mac it was a
republican candidate
but basically they saw they they thought
out of all of them they're like Trump is
so ridiculous that there's no way that
he would have won and that would have
been the best candidate to go up against
like Ted Cruz at the time maybe he was
oh yeah he was done right yeah yeah oh
Jeb Jeb Bush he was dunking on everybody
yeah yeah but who would have been in the
primaries who who had the best chance
aside from Trump right they were afraid
of someone the Democratic uh National
Committee was afraid of someone in the
Republican primaries so they boosted uh
Trump thinking that it'll be a big joke
whatever whatever and then it flipped
yeah because it was supposed to be a
layup for the clintons right for Hillary
oh yeah it was supposed to was like dude
she got this remember Nate silver of of
uh 538 said the day of the morning of
the election he is a 90 she has a 90
[__] two percent chance of winning
some [__] and I remember during the
election she was like smoking the whole
time yeah she was smoking them and then
where were you the moment Trump was uh
announced president uh I was I was up
out front I was [__] happy
yeah I had like two sparklers in my hand
and I was going like that you know
what's funny because I was in college at
that time
I was storming the capital before it was
cool man
yeah
there's some yellows in there I remember
the day after Trump got elected I had
classes at Northridge I was I was in
college I remember everybody was like
like
everybody was such a somber feeling it
felt like after 9 11. people were like
crying people were and then like the
teachers were like I understand
everyone's feeling a little upset about
the election but we still have to get
through today's Court what a difference
we worked at like a rehab we worked at
like an aquatic rehab center that was
like one of our classes that we had to
do we had to work with like oh oh yeah
yeah yeah right and then but then the
whole time they're like it's okay so we
shouldn't go through the day I
understand if you guys were feeling like
not okay everybody goes underwater and
cries drowns themselves
all right
let's go
yeah
that was a good time dude Nick's doing
cannonballs in that [__] it's backflips
I wish at a I was at Toca Madera you
know that place where Geo's birthday was
at it's like this Hollywood like you
guys were celebrating too no we were
there at night when they announced like
when the you could see like the map and
the numbers and everything and everybody
just started like crying bro like that
oh [__] because this is Hollywood oh it
was Hollywood so everybody was just like
like you could see like just grown ass
dudes just going [__] [__] it it's over
it's [__] over like they're just like
life is done it's so funny but I love
that we made politics Sports I know so
you [__] love it it's the national
championship I didn't think that when I
saw like when I saw his reaction he
looked surprised
he's like holy [__] [__] what am I
gonna do and then there's even a
comedian that made fun of her like he
was like he didn't think he was gonna
win but it all makes sense now uh once
this news came out about the Hillary
campaign funding Trump then it was like
oh that makes a lot of sense because
maybe I mean they've been buddies him
and the clintons they've been buddies
for so many years right so it it could
have been that it's like okay like you
you you be my opponent right and then
like sure yeah and what is he gonna do
once he's president is he gonna go
actually Hillary's the real winner here
all right so let me just give this to
her you know it's like it's like boxing
to pad your record yeah yeah but he
would just go accidentally won yeah yeah
dude that's one of those jobs too like
you sit there and you're the president
and you wake up and you just go in the
office and like
[Laughter]
so how does this work like it's like
Tommy Boy checking out the phone
remember Tommy Boy where he's like
working at his dad's company and he's
just playing with a fan
but that's what it's like you've never
done that job before only a couple
people have right what the [__] do you
do in day one what do you even do prank
call the Pentagon yeah there you go day
one done all day they just want to check
this is still cool thank you demand
access to area 51. day one I just want
to go see the aliens the um a lot of
people are also thinking that it's not
really it's like a ploy it's probably
not really gonna happen also like I
think Taco Carlson was saying something
about like it doesn't sound likely that
it would um take place in the sense that
the D.A that's going after him is is uh
not a federal it's like it's not federal
charges but he's a state D.A so it's not
enough to stick you can't pursue a
federal charge oh did you see the jury
one of the jury people from this no one
of the people from the grand jury came
out and did a media tour for some
[__] reason they could do that before
a truck and this chick was like
she's like working again and she's like
[__] popping and locking I'm not
kidding like it was like weird she was
like yeah and after this happened the
jury after this happened everyone in the
media who obviously like the people who
hate Trump on the media they're all like
this is [__] up it's like why'd she do
this like this is gonna [__] up the
trial this is weird so yeah it was
really odd we should we should we all
you do that I'll send you the videos as
a grandchild I know exactly well you can
you can talk about like I think you
could talk around things but you can't
talk about [__] like you're rooting for
it like she's meeting up with Mean Gene
to do like an interview right we want
they excuse her after seeing something
like that would be important yeah I
would assume so but it's like someone
going through an active trials going on
a book tour yeah
that's like being a referee in the Super
Bowl you're wearing an eagles Jersey
[Laughter]
okay no I'm neutral dude I swear to God
I swear to [__] God and then Eagles
score
so that is um that's a PR I think elon's
pretty
um on point though it's like the more
[__] happens to him that makes him like
look like a victim of this entire like
Ploy the system yeah it will become a
victim of the system this he will use
the system to to win that's that's the
thing man right and it sort of proves
his points right people hate like the
elites
in media and like there's already a
narrative of like it hasn't been a good
a good four years alterations you know
all these in snobby-ass like
um you know virtue signalers and trust
is down for sure yeah and yeah a [__]
you know everyone's tired of Joe Biden
dude I hear everyone just even people
that are like very do you know anybody
that's like used to be about Joe that is
now like no I've never met anyone who
liked Joe Biden I knew Bernie people
that's it Bernie people Bernie people
yeah there's so many more candidates
from the left that were so like they had
real supporters yeah I don't know anyone
that was like I can't wait till Joe
Biden [__] wins yeah you know the
only people that I do think
we're rooting for him or is the older
generation that wanted people they like
establishment [__] uh because they come
like they come from that like oh
remember the good old days when
everything was more chill and I think in
their their argument was always well
he's been in office from Obama he knows
what he's doing Trump he's like a
business guy who knows where his head is
all these other like people they're too
radical so they're like let's let's get
a safe middle guy but they don't think
in terms of oh that guy is just a
corporate dog right like now our
generation is more like oh yeah they
have establishment candidates who take
tons of money from corporations whether
it's right or left it doesn't matter
they're the same camp and then their
generation is they still believe in the
right and the left and then you know
they're actually meaning what they say
so it's corporatist America right like
corporatist America owns both parties
and then they just want to get all their
[__] through and everything else be down
and even though that's a fact their
generation will hear that and think it's
some hippie conspiracy [__] yeah so
I think that's just a divide and does
our generation vote no our Our
Generation I mean even us and younger
Millennials and younger just don't vote
so who's actually voting it's the senior
citizens that are making decisions for
the whole country when you go to a
polling theater that's mainly who's
there because they're the ones that care
and then they they listen to the old
school politics because that's what
they're comfortable with yeah all this
new stuff is way too radical and it's
scary I find it kind of ironic too that
when when Trump was elected president
everybody was like that dude runs his
mouth so much he's gonna get us into a
war his whole term no more
and now damn okay what's going on bro
I'm just hanging out North Korea shaking
hands he was like chilling whatever it's
kind of funny to me that is so funny
that was wild when he walked into North
Korea that was [__] wild who would
have thought that was gonna happen the
narrative was was like oh we're gonna
get into war with North Korea dude I
remember being he's gonna pop his gums
off I was on the phone I was on the
phone with like a bunch of Hollywood
people when like he was pissing off
North Korea and they're like well we
might not even live through the weekend
like [__] like that like all right they
really thought they're like oh we're
gonna get nuked over the weekend like
they were really saying this [__] like
like normally like just completely
normal because he did a switch where he
antagonized the [__] out of them and
then he flipped and then he went over
there and shook his hand and everyone
was like
now that I look back it's like oh man
that is exactly what I did to like
bullies in high school like it's like
you you come at them and you're like hey
[__] don't pick on me you could pick
on anybody else don't [__] pick on me
[__] and then they like kind of
do this thing where they're like hey
work chill right we're cool now it's all
good and that's kind of what that's
exactly what he did is he just did some
high school [__]
foreign